Dr Mary bastard joint General Secretary
for the National Education Union is with
us now seems pretty overwhelming of
those who voted what happens next
uh well we what we hope happens next
okay is that do you think Keegan picks
up the phone uh contacts me and Kevin
and says come in and let's have more
negotiations and let's try and resolve
this dispute because we have three weeks
before the next strike and we would
really like to resolve it in that period
what do you want
we want a much better payoffer we want a
better pay offer for this year and
better for next year because at one
thousand pounds which doesn't
um which isn't incorporating to pay and
4.3 next year does nothing uh to
compensate teachers for the huge loss in
their earnings since 2010 and they've
lost more than any other occupational
group in dispute with the government it
does nothing to keep teachers in our
schools and it does nothing to encourage
graduates to become Teachers Pay is now
so poor that it's become a massive
problem simply getting teachers in our
schools now Jillian Keegan the education
secretary said if you reject the offer
your members they have the decision will
be passed back to the pay review body
that offered uh three percent
recommended three percent uh and more
than that the one thousand pound one-off
payment that your members have been
offered would be taken off the table
well our members knew that we were very
clear with them about the conditions
under which the government was putting
forward this offer we made that very
clear in information and they rejected
it and I think Jillian Keegan needs to
stop the bullying tactics she needs to
start reading the room she needs to
start listening to teachers these are
not Union Barons it's not me making
members reject this offer they had a
free private vote either by text or by
email it was not a crowded room where
people were intimidated or forced into
rejecting so they know what they're
rejecting they know it's not good enough
they know it will not they and
uncrucially they know it's not properly
funded they know that even this offer if
it is paid out either children will have
less equipment or there'll be fewer
support staff in schools so they want to
fully funded much better offer and Kay
if we are to keep our schools running
the crisis is now so poor that we have
routinely children being taught by
teachers who are not special this in the
subjects they're teaching government
missing 41 of its secondary training
Targets this year looks likely to be
doing just as badly next year we can't
carry on like this we have to pay
teachers properly get more of them in
the profession and get our schools
working properly for the children and
the young people who deserve a decent
education okay it looks as though your
miles apart doesn't know how this is
going to impact on exams isn't it
well we are saying today that we're
asking all the local districts and they
will do this to have dispensations for
children taking exams in years 11 and
year 13. we want them in school
preparing for their exams and we will
make local arrangements to make sure
that happens so it will not disrupt the
exam work because that is the last thing
we want to do so we're responsible
people we are responsible profession
those children taking exams will not
have their education disrupted
would you accept uh what the teachers in
Wales and Scotland have been offered
well that would certainly be a basis for
a decent offer well being well in
Scotland the offer is much better in
Wales it is considerably better and I do
ask Julian Keegan why does she think
that teachers in England are worth so
much less than teachers in Wales and
Scotland it is a ridiculous situation
and it's one that can't be ignored any
longer
okay for now thank you